sehr geehrter Herr Präsident
sehr geehrter Herr Bundeskanzler Werte
Damen und Herren der lärmende Fehlstart
den ihre aus linksgrün Beton Köpfen und
umgefallene Liberalen zusammen
gezimmerte Regierung hingelegt hat sucht
seinesgleichen von der ersten Minute an
geben sie und ihre Minister auf
Konfrontationskurs mit der Realität mit
der Freiheit mit dem Bürgerrechten mit
den Bürgern und mit den europäischen
Nachbarn und Partner Herr Habeck und
sein Staatssekretär haben sich als
erstes Projekt die Aushebelung des
Artenschutzes vorgenommen um das Land
noch dichter mit Windrädern vorstellen
zu können der Natur und Artenschutz hat
als Sympathie Werbung bei den Grünen
offenbar an Bedeutung verloren und das
unsägliche zensurgesetz letzte g wollte
die FDP im Wahlkampf noch abschaffen
jetzt stellt sie den Justizminister der
die Anwendung des netzdg sogar noch
schärfen will in Ministerin Feser
erklärt kaum im Amt den
Rechtsextremismus zur größten Gefahr der
allgegenwärtige igus oder klatschen der
allgegenwärtige links und Islam
Extremismus kommt bei ihr genauso wenig
vor wie im ganzen rot grün gelben
Koalitionsvertrag nicht mit einem Wort
zu dem soeben mit knapper Not in Hamburg
verhinderten islamistischen Terror
Anschlag haben wir von der
Innenministerin bis heute noch kein Wort
gehört und dieselbe in Ministerin
Kahnert brutzelt zurück mit der Zusage
von 40000 Afghan die aus unerfindlichen
Gründen in die EU umgesiedelt werden
sollen gleich
25000 allein nach Deutschland zu holen
Spanien und Frankreich übernehmen gerade
mal ein Zehntel dieser Zahl und das
obwohl die Asylanträge ohne wieder stark
ansteigen und Deutschland EU-weit mit
Abstand die meisten Asylbewerber
aufnimmt und damit ist klar Deutschland
bleibt nicht nur auf seinem Sonderweg
als migrationspaket der
Vorgängerregierung ihre Regierung gibt
in dieser Sackgasse sogar noch Vollgas
und die gleiche moralische Anmaßung
steckt hinter den Belehrung die Frau
baerbock als Außenministerin gegenüber
Polen meinte verteilen zu müssen weil
das Land Polen
seine europäische Verantwortung ernst
nimmt und die EU Außengrenze wirksam
gegen illegale Migration schützt und
Herr Lindner
von der Umfaller Partei FDP der in
ferner Vergangenheit gern und viel von
soliden Staatsfinanzen
Sprache und versprach liegt als erstes
einen Nachtragshaushalt von 60
Milliarden Schulden vor
als Notar der kommenden grün-roten
Ausgaben Orgien
zweckentfremdet der Bundesfinanzminister
also überdimensionierte
kreditermächtigung seines Vorgängers und
des Bundeskanzlers um künftig noch mehr
Geld für grüne Klimaschutz und
Energiewende Planwirtschaft verpulvern
zu können was für ein Start ins Amt mit
unserer lösen und verfassungsrechtlich
bedenklich und Finanzkrise rein vor 4
Jahren Helena wie ist es bei ihnen noch
lieber gar nicht regieren als schlecht
regieren heute lautet die Devise
Hauptsache in der Regierung sitzen als
Steigbügelhalter für Grün linke Projekte
und Allmachtsphantasien
von dem einstigen bei der FDP das muss
man dir mal ganz klar sagen ist nichts
aber auch gar nichts mehr übrig
geblieben und inmitten dieses
dissonanten Konzert steht als
Kapellmeister ein Bundeskanzler der vor
allem eins gerne tut Schweigen vor allem
seinen eigenen Verfehlungen von cum-ex
über Wirecard bis zur Million fernsteuer
und Spendenaffäre der Warburg Bank und
ihre Orakel haften Zweideutigkeiten nach
Merkel Art machen die Sache nicht besser
sie sagen sie seien auch der Kanzler der
ungeimpften und sortieren genau damit
die Bürger in brave geimpfte und
ungeimpfte Abweichler die sie zum
Wohlverhalten zwingen wollen genau das
ist die Wortwahl eines Kanzlers der
Spaltung
DWK Tante zum Wähler betrug haben sie
sich noch vor Amtsantritt geleistet
den Einstieg in die vor wenigen Wochen
noch hoch und heilig dementierte
Impfpflicht die Novelle des
Infektionsschutzgesetzes wurde gegen
alle guten parlamentarischen Sitten
durchgepeitscht dies mit weiteren
schweren grundrechtseinschränkung auf
unabsehbare Zeit
warum sie es damit so eilig hatten ist
leicht zu durchschauen das Virus schert
sich nämlich nicht um ihre Maßnahmen ihr
ständiges immer mehr was bisher schon
nicht funktioniert hat sie wollen
nämlich an der Verfassung vorbei einen
unerklärten permanenten Ausnahmezustand
etablieren und wir befürchten nämlich
dass die von Ihnen geführte Panik zu
schnell ab wenn das infektions geschehen
auch ohne ihr Zutun schon wieder zurück
geht sie brauchen dauerpanik und
Ausnahmezustand damit weniger über das
gesprochen wird was ihre Regierung sonst
noch auf der Agenda hat eine
Migrationspolitik die noch mehr als die
Vorgängerregierung die Tore für
Einwanderung in die Sozialsysteme öffnet
die mit erleichterten Zugang zu
Sozialleistungen und
Aufenthaltserlaubnis and locked die über
die großzügige Ausweitung von
Einbürgerung und Familienzusammenführung
unumkehrbare tatsachen schafft eine
Klimaschutzpolitik die allen
wirtschaftlichen und gesellschaftlichen
Bereichen übergeordnet ist und über
staatliche Lenkung und staatliches Geld
verteilen faktisch in Sozialismus und
Klima Planwirtschaft mündet und in die
Verarmung breiter
Bevölkerungsschichten Energie und
Sicherheit und absehbare Blackouts
Europapolitik die von eigenen nationalen
Interessen nichts wissen will die
Schulden und Transferunion zum Nachteil
der deutschen Steuerzahler weiter
ausbaut und die EU in einem europäischen
Bundesstaat umbauen möchte mit diesem
Wunsch nach Auflösung des eigenen
Nationalstaates in einem EU Zentralstaat
stehen sie ein ropa in Europa übrigens
völlig alleine da und das alles steht
bei ihnen unter dem Schlagwort
Transformation aber eine solche Macht
Anmaßung ist nicht die Aufgabe einer
demokratischen Regierung die den Bürgern
dient
auf die realen Sorgen und Nöte welche
die ganz normalen Bürger dieses Landes
umtreiben haben sie keine Antwort
Deflation läuft aus dem Ruder und lässt
Mittelstand und Mittelschicht verarmen
die EZB ist hilflos sie müsste mit
höheren Zinsen gegensteuern aber sie
sitzt gefangen in der Falle der Staats
und Unternehmensfinanzierung von 0 und
Negativzinsen die Notenbanken im übrigen
eigentlich verboten ist Stadt die Bürger
zu entlasten treibt ihre Regierung
Steuern sowie Sprit und Energiepreise
noch in die Höhe und das ist
unverantwortlich sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren
die Angst um den Arbeitsplatz geht um
sie aber Blasen im Namen des
Klimaschutzes zum Generalangriff auf dem
produktiven industriellen Kern und die
Energieversorgung dieses Land ist sie
schauen dem Niedergang der Automobil und
Zulieferindustrie sogar mit Genugtuung
zu und vergeuden Steuergeld für Grün
linke Identitätspolitik wo sie Jobs auf
Kosten der Allgemeinheit für ihre
Lobbygruppen schaffen und die innere
Sicherheit erodiert vor eskalierender
Messer Gewalt
Rohheitsdelikte und der wachsenden
Unsicherheit auf den Straßen
verschließen Sie die Augen dafür
kriminalisieren sie umso mehr mit
größerem Eifer
regierungskritische Proteste während
recht Treue Bürger ohne digitalen
Impfpass kein Restaurant betreten dürfen
bleiben die Grenzen offen für illegale
Einwanderer auch ohne Ausweisdokumente
das ist
eine unhaltbare völlig rechtswidrige
Politik die diese Regierung
verschlimmert und verstetigt und der
Bundeskanzler Scholz ihre Regierung
hat bereits in den ersten Tagen
überdeutlich gemacht wohin die Reise mit
dieser Koalition gehen soll es ist eine
Geisterfahrt
korrigieren Sie diesen Kurs sorgen sie
für die Einhaltung des Rechts die
Wiederherstellung der Gerechtigkeit
einen Sie dieses Land statt es weiter zu
spalten ich bedanke mich
vielen Dank Frau Kollegin
Herr Doktor Seidel